good morning Hank it's Tuesday in a
stunning turn of events I have found
myself in an airport I'm here because
I'm on my way to Brazil to attend the
Paper Towns premiere there and actually
I won't be returning home to my beloved
Indianapolis International Airport for
28 days except for a brief sojourn
thanks to the love and support of
nerdfighteria but more on that in a
moment
all right I think I have a bunch of news
first bad news my daughter alice is a
little bit sick she threw up this
morning and it was just horrible to
watch because in addition to like the
regular miseries of throwing up children
can't understand what's happening to
them so she was just like wait why is
something coming out of my mouth my
mouth is for putting things in but she
doesn't have a very good vocabulary so
she just kept saying no I was
heartbreaking okay hang on to some
slightly better news cara delevingne nat
wolff halston sage and I are going on a
brief tour of the United States before
the Paper Towns movie comes out
basically everyone could vote for their
state on tumblr and the winning States
were Ohio Texas and my own home state of
Indiana heck it is not lost on me that
Indiana is a relatively small state that
received a lot of votes from kind people
who do not live here but just thought
that I might enjoy having a day with my
family so thank you thank you thank you
so Hank will be in indianapolis July
14th Columbus Ohio July 15th and Dallas
Texas July 16th all the events are free
they will be crazy fun lots of surprises
I don't know the venues and the times
yet but I should sometime in the next
week I will let you know and even more
good news last night Sarah and a bunch
of my friends saw the Paper Towns movie
for the first time and they all really
liked it or else they're good at lying
but no I do think they really like did
they laugh they felt things it was good
but in terrible news way too really none
of them noticed my cameo in the movie I
mean Hank at the end of the movie my
life partner of more than a decade
turned to me and said that was such a
great movie I thought you said that you
were in it where were you
so yeah Hank I am in the movie but
apparently in a way that no one will
notice okay even more good news Hank the
night before the Paper Towns movie
actually comes out in the United States
on July 24th there will be a special
event at a couple hundred theaters on
the night of July 23rd the night of July
23rd is going to be like the first real
public showing of the movie in the US
and I'm so excited about it and then
afterwards there's gonna be this like
livestream beamed into theaters around
the country featuring the whole cast and
also special guests I'm not allowed to
name I'm just really excited to
celebrate the movie with the whole cast
and with the people who care the most
about the story so yeah we're going to
answer
questions and sing-songs is going to be
tons of fun night on the town's calm
there's a link in the doobly-doo alright
Hank now to the news that for many years
I thought would be bad but I think
actually might turn out to be kind of
great sewing more than 10 years ago I
sold the movie rights to my first novel
Looking for Alaska and as you know since
then I have frequently tried to get them
back I think there's a big part of me
that never wanted a Looking for Alaska
movie to be made the story is very
personal to me I know it matters a lot
to a lot of its readers so then again
the money we made from selling the movie
rights was extremely important to us it
allowed us to move to New York so Sara
could go to graduate school and pursue
her dream of becoming a curator so I
could never really regret it but as you
know Hank over the years it's been
difficult for me I've had some mixed
feelings about it
but Hank suddenly it seems like the
movie isn't just going to happen it's
going to happen in a way that I can be
really proud of whoever in Neustadter
who also wrote the screenplays for The
Fault in Our Stars and Paper Towns have
written a beautiful script and Becca
Thomas who previously directed the movie
electric children has just been hired to
direct Looking for Alaska and that means
that it's probably gonna happen it might
still fall apart things often do but now
I hope that it doesn't because I really
like Becca and she gets the book all the
way down so yeah I am excited about the
prospect of the Looking for Alaska movie
our words I never thought I would say
but I am I hope you guys are excited too
and I hope you're excited for the Paper
Towns movie I know that it's scary when
a book is turned into a movie I mean it
is very scary for me but it's exciting
too so I think that's the news oh wait a
couple more pieces of good news the
United States Supreme Court did not
cancel our health insurance Hank and
also no matter who you are and no matter
where you live in the United States you
can marry the person you love here's to
the activists and decades of activism
that made that happen Hank I'll see you
on Friday
psh I tried to bring a champagne popper
into the airport so I could have a big
huzzah at the end of the video it turns
out that's not allowed